on sort charles bonsoir solide vous
intéresser aujourd'hui à l'écosystème du
saint-laurent notamment aux algues qui
ont un potentiel insoupçonné
oui c'est vraiment remarquable en fait
on on exploite les ied dans l'asie du
sud est depuis très longtemps maintenant
on a commencé à le faire en europe et il
ya plusieurs façons de le faire
évidemment on peut exploiter les stocks
existants de la façon la plus durable
possible et ça c'est pas vraiment
évident réussir cet exploit là c'est
difficile
l'autre façon qui est beaucoup plus
répandue en asie du sud-est en europe et
même même dans la baie de fundy
maintenant au canada c'est l'aquaculture
de cultiver les algues afin de protéger
des écosystèmes et de bien contrôler la
production
ce qu'il faut dire c'est que les algues
ont des propriétés uniques sur le plan
alimentaire sont des végétaux marins
dont elles ont une évolution qui est
tout à fait différent de ces végétaux
terrestres et elvis baigné dans un
milieu qui est très riche en minéraux
donc elles vont ce sont des pompes et
des éponges et minéraux elles vont
absorber concentrer les minéraux du
milieu marin et comme ils ont une
génétique et une bio chimique et qui est
différent des plantes et restent elles
ont elles vont synthétiser des molécules
qui n'existe pas chez les plantes
terrestres
donc elles vont avoir des propriétés qui
sont tout à fait surprenants et on
s'intéresse aussi charlot potentiel
thérapeutique des algues
oui c'est vraiment remarquable ces
algues peuvent vraiment agir en tant
qu'antioxydants anti inflammatoire anti
microbiens elles peuvent même avoir une
action vraiment utile pour contrer les
tumeurs donc pour lutter contre le
cancer
c'est donc quelque chose de remarquable
qui attire les experts qui attire les
chercheurs éventuellement on passait une
exploitation commerciale
mais on est encore loin de cela au
québec
bon il ya l'autre ressources à laquelle
on s'intéresse aussi c'est le créneau ce
sont ces petites crevettes qui servent
notamment de nourriture aux baleines oui
et d'ailleurs
les recherches sont sont quand même
assez poussée dans ce domaine là parce
qu'il y à du crilan aussi dans le golfe
du saint laurent dans l'estuaire du
saint-laurent le krill va nourrir les
baleines bien sûr les s'est assis comme
le cétacé comme et rorqual bleu et aussi
de nombreuses espèces de poissons
donc des recherches se font ici pour
essayer de caractériser les stocks pour
savoir exactement qu'est ce qui lie à
nancy stock là quelles sont les espèces
de cribles que nous avons dans
l'estuaire et dans le golfe
comment elle vit comment se crée il se
nourrit mais c'est vraiment une tâche
difficile sur le plan de la recherche
scientifique écoutons il ya plusieurs
espèces de créer et d espèce de krill
qui sont qui semble avoir des affinités
ou être plus associé aux environnements
d'obtempérer
d'autres sont d'origine arctique donc
avec les changements climatiques ou les
variations environnementales qu'on
observe à l'échelle des dernières
décennies il est fort probable que ces
espèces le salon certains conditions
environnementales
ce ne serait pas favorisé de la même
manière ou défavorisés
si les changements climatiques devaient
modifier le comportement du cri le
comportement alimentaire du krill il
faudrait que les grandes baleines et
toutes les autres espèces marines qui
s'en nourrissent modifie aussi leurs
comportements alimentaires et il semble
bien nous disent les experts que c'est
tout à fait possible
alors c'est une bonne nouvelle vous
souhaitez à une bonne fin de congrès
merci beaucoup aux charges et sur un
plaisir de vous avoir à l'émission merci
c'est réciproque merci céline